皆さん　こんにちは
道元です
今日は
ＡＰＵ（立命館アジア太平洋大学）に来ています
僕は以前 ここで
学生募集の仕事をしていて
過去に このチャンネルで
ＡＰＵについての動画を投稿しました
例えば アメリカの高校から
直接 日本の大学に
行けることを伝えたかった
日本に興味を
持っている高校生のために
僕も高校生だったら知りたかったよ
あの動画を上げた時—
当然 多くの学生から質問が来て
実際に ここで学んでいる学生や
先生方の話を聞きたいという声が多かった
というわけで
今回もＡＰＵとのタイアップ動画になります
この大学の学生や職員から
直接 話を聞きます
その前に
大学に関する基本的な情報を—
改めてお伝えします
“立命館アジア太平洋大学
南日本のグローバルな大学”
ＡＰＵは別府にあります
別府は九州の大分県にあり
九州は日本の４つの大きな島の１つで
南西部に位置します
ＡＰＵには約6000人 の学生が
在学しており
アメリカの大学や日本の他の大きな大学と
比べると規模が小さいほうです
ＡＰＵの特色で興味深いのは—
在学生 そして職員の半数が
海外から来ているという環境であることです
だから 職員と学生の
半数は日本人で
もう半数は海外の
約103カ国･地域から来ています
大学は日本にあるけれど—
従来の日本の大学とは違った感じで
国際的な雰囲気です
常に いろんな言語が聞こえてきて
様々なバックグラウンドを持った人々がいる
とてもユニークです
“ここは本当に日本なのか？”と
不思議に思うくらい
どちらかと言うと
空港にいるような感覚です
最初に３人の
ＡＰＵ生に会いました
ケニア出身のサロメさんは
アジア太平洋学部（ＡＰＳ）の３年生
アメリカ出身のスペロさんは
国際経営学部（ＡＰＭ）の２年生
インドネシア出身のシャーリーさんは
同じく国際経営学部（ＡＰＭ）の３年生です
ゲストとして ３名のＡＰＵ生に
来てもらいました
これが動画の肝心な部分です
本人たちから直接 話を聞けます
まず 日本に来た経緯と その中でも
なぜＡＰＵに来たのかを教えてください
最初はアメリカの大学に
行く予定だったんだ
ウィスコンシン大学ラクロス校に
行こうと思っていたんだけど
ネットの友達が
当時イギリスに留学していて
“海外留学の選択肢もあるよ”って
僕は大学の費用が心配だったからね
そうだよね　アメリカは
よく考えると
海外留学をしたほうが安いんだ
そんなことができるのかと思ってた
当時はコロナ禍で学校はオンライン授業だった
暇つぶしの趣味として
日本語を勉強し始めたんだ
そして ふざけて日本の大学を調べて
まあ行かないけどって感じだったけど
道元の動画でＡＰＵが紹介されていて
まだ入学者を募集していたから—
出願したんだ
いい大学だと思った
日本語を学べるだけでなく
他の分野を専攻できる
そんなわけで 今ここにいるんだ
ＡＰＵ卒業後は
何をする予定ですか？
そして その準備に
勉強していることは？
私は教育に
とても興味があるの
インドネシアの小さな町で
育ったから—
小さな町と大きな都市では
教育格差があると感じて
長期的な目標としては
祖国に戻って教育プロジェクトを立ち上げたい
今はビジネスと国際経営学を
勉強していて
特に社会的企業に興味があるから
主に社会的企業に焦点を
当てたゼミの授業を取ってるわ
私の祖国 ケニアでは
女性に関する課題が多いわ
女性の権利や教育など
私はそれらに興味を持ってる
だから そのどれかの分野で
大学院に進学したいの
そして祖国に戻り
ＮＧＯを立ち上げて
地域へ働きかけ 女性に教育を受けさせて
権利を獲得させたい
それが私の目標よ
すばらしい
ありがとう
僕は２人より年下で
まだ２年生の１学期だから
どこで何をするのかは
まだ決めてないんだけど
ＡＰＵに来て会計に興味を
持つようになったんだ
理解しやすいよ
勉強しなくても分かる
貸方にしろ 借方にしろ
株だったら こういう仕組みだろうと思って
本当にそうだった
論理的だよね
そうなんだ
自分にはこの道が合ってると思う
それで 日本の会社で
会計をやるのか—
カナダやニュージーランド
ヨーロッパの国でやるか
まだ決めていなんだ
もう少し時間がかかると思う
その上 会計の分野の中でも
会計監査をしたいのか 会計アシスタントにするか
学びながら決めようと思う
ＡＰＵで過ごす一日は
どんな流れですか？
朝起きてから
ゴミ出しまで
夕方にね
私にはルームメイトがいるから
起きたら私が—
“起きて”って
分かる？
“なんで？”って
言うから
“バスの時間に
間に合わない”って答えるの
それから身支度をして
一緒に朝食を食べて
バスに乗って
そこには他のＡＰＵ生が大勢いるの
みんなも朝早く起きて
ケータイを見つめていて 学校って感じよ
キャンパスに着いたら
授業に向かうわ
その日の授業を受けて
授業が４コマある日もあれば
１コマの日もあるわ
授業が終わったら 友達と過ごしたり
図書館で勉強したりして
それからバスに乗って帰るわ
夕方は夕食を作って
課題をやる
たまに別府の いいお店で
外食することもあるわ
帰ったら
寝る準備をして就寝よ
私の一日はそんな感じかな
みんなは？
僕もＡＰハウスではなく
街の方に住むようになったんだけど
僕は絶対に起きれないから
１限の授業は１つも取ってない
早起きするのが好きな人もいるけど
僕には無理だから
僕は大体８〜９時まで寝て
起きてからは
シリアルを食べるかな
ギリギリまで寝た時は
学校に着いてからローソンか学食に行く
学食は すごくいいよ
そこで何か食べて
授業に行く
今学期は日本語の授業は取ってなくて
サークル活動に集中してるんだ
普段はサプライ・チェーン・マネジメントとか
その日の授業を受けて
午後は 日によっては
アルバイトをする
それは英語を
教える仕事なんだけど
仕事先が遠い時もあって
福岡に行ったりするよ
本当？
はい　とても楽しいんだ
その中で課題と
サークルの時間をやりくりしてる
かなり忙しいね
すごく忙しい
私は ある意味
早起きしないといけない状況で
５日間の ４日は１限があるの
１限は何時から？
8:45よ
だけど—
私はいつもルームメイトと
早めに学校に行くの
毎朝 学食では100円朝食が
販売されていて
ご飯と味噌汁に
小鉢が３つ付いてくる
私たちは それを毎朝
利用してるくらい気に入ってるわ
その後は
ひたすら授業を受ける
たまに 数日間のインターンシップが
授業後にあるから
観光案内所に行ったり
ガイドとして観光客に
別府を案内したりする
その後は集まりが多いかな
勉強会を開いたり
サークル活動で集まったり
これが私の一日よ
100円朝食がいいなと思った
しっかりした食事みたいだね
本当に いい食事よ
結構お金の節約になるね
お金と言えば—
別府に住むのは
比較的 安い
世界の どの都市と比べてもね
もちろん東京や
テンプル大学は もっと高い
いい大学だけど
別府みたいな街のほうが
お金を節約できる
ちょっと個人的な話に
なってしまうけど—
ＡＰＵでは いろんな
奨学金制度があって
奨学金をもらってるか
差し支えなければ教えてほしい
もし大丈夫だったら
大丈夫だよ
ええ　大丈夫よ
僕はＡＰＵの制度で
授業料の65%が減免されていて
授業料減免率には
いくつか種類がある
もともと金銭的な理由で
海外留学を選んだ僕としては—
すごく助かる
おかげで自分で
生計を立てられる
親に頼ったり
借金したりする必要がない
生活に困らないから
本当によかったよ
ＡＰＵの１年間の授業料は—
今日2022年11月の
米ドル／円のレートで換算すると
１年間で約１万ドルです
君は その65%が
減免されるから
3000ドルくらいだよ
あり得ないくらい安くなる
アメリカのコミュニティ･
カレッジより安いよ
親に頼ったり
借金したりせずに
自分で生活していけるのが
信じられない
そのとおりだよ
そして先程も言ったけど—
別府は とても住みやすい街だ
家賃を聞いてもいい？
僕もルームシェアをしてるから
広めの所がよくて
３ＬＤＫにしたんだ
３ＬＤＫには３つの部屋とリビングに
ダイニングとキッチンがあるんだ
光熱費を含めて
自分は約４万円を払ってるよ
換算すると350ドルくらい？
300ドルくらいかな
そう　毎月それくらいだね
かなり住みやすいよ
そうだね　２人も家賃は
大体 同じくらいかな？
同じくらいよ
私も
家賃を折半するから
もっと安いかも
ルームメイトとね
２人も授業料は減免されてる？
私は ありがたいことに
100％減免されていて
学費は なし
それ以外にも追加で
奨学金をもらっていて
さっきのは
授業料の免除だけど—
生活費については
入学後に申請できる制度があるの
それで 主に２年生以降から
いくつか申請して
生活費の一部をカバーしてくれて
とても ありがたいわ
かなり お金を節約できる
それと100円朝食で
もう完璧だね
ええ
すごく いいね
そして 君は？
私もシャーリーと
同じような感じで
幸運なことに私も
授業料100％減免されている
そしてＪＡＳＳＯという
学生支援機構の奨学金制度があって
ＪＡＳＳＯは日本の独立した組織で
ＡＰＵと提携している
学問的に優れた
学生を支援したり
学問や課外活動を
追求し続けたい学生を支援してくれる
私は その奨学金をもらっていて
とても助かってるわ
家賃を払えるし 交通費も安くなる
日常の細かい出費も
まかなえる
じゃ今から
日本語で ちょっと話します
答えは日本語でも
英語でも大丈夫
大丈夫
ありがとうございます
はい
日本語を勉強してＡＰＵに入ったんですか？
それとも 入ってから勉強したんですか？
私はＡＰＵに入る前に
少し日本語を勉強しました
たくさんは勉強しませんでした
そして ＡＰＵに
初めて来てから—
私は たくさん日本語を
勉強しました
ＡＰＵには
とてもいい日本語の授業があります
その授業の中で
特別な教科書があったり
専門の先生がいたり
活動があります
私の場合は—
日本に来る前は
日本語を全然 勉強してなかったです
じゃあ 日本に来てから
初めて日本語を…
ＡＰＵに入ってから
日本語の勉強を始めました
それと日本語の言語の
紹介をもらいました　授業で
どうやってカタカナとか漢字とか
いや漢字じゃなくて ひらがな
ああ　ひらがな
一番 簡単なのを勉強しました
シャーリーの場合は
どうですか？
私はＡＰＵに入る前は
日本語はゼロ
ゼロだったんですね
今も上手じゃない
いやいや　上手　上手
そう　ＡＰＵに入る前はゼロで
ＡＰＵをきっかけに
日本語という言語に触れて勉強し始めました
それからは
授業外の活動があって
例えばＡＰハウスに住んでいる
国内学生と話したり
ティーチング･アシスタントや
レジデント･アシスタントとして活動したり
そこでは日本人の同僚に
会えるから
それで日本語を
伸ばすことができると思う
スペロさんはＡＰＵに入って
今 何年でしたっけ？
今 私は２年生の１学期です
いや すごいな
だって日本語が専攻じゃないのに
普通に
こうやって話せるから
僕の場合は
日本語が専攻だったんだけど—
多分 こうやってカメラの前で
話せなかったと思うんだよね
緊張しすぎて
とても緊張してるから
だから逆にビジネス･ケース･
コンペティションとかの経験が—
こういう時によく使えるっていうか
緊張せずに話せるじゃん？
でもケース･コンペティションの時は
英語でやりますから
英語でも人の前に立って
発表するじゃん？
だからその自信が…
自信を持っていました
とても普通のことになりました
そう　だよね
だから　なんか
日本語が完璧じゃなくても
それ以外のスキルを身に付けることで—
日本語も より自然になるというか
もっと使えるというか
すばらしい！
今日は ありがとうございました
皆さんには明るい未来が待っています
皆さんの ご活躍を期待しています
ありがとうございました
次に 言語教育センター長の
本田明子教授と お話ししました
本田教授はＡＰＵが開学した2000年の４月から
本学で日本語を教えています
はい　それでは今
本田先生の研究室に来ています
主にＡＰＵの日本語教育について
質問をしたいと思うのですが—
まず簡単に自己紹介をしていただいても
よろしいでしょうか？
はい　私は本田明子です
いつも学生に
自己紹介をするときは—
“皆さん　ホンダ知ってますか”と聞くと
大体みんな知ってると言うので
“Honda 有名な車の会社ですね”と
“私の名前は本田です
でも私の車はトヨタです”と言うと—
大体みんな
一度で名前を覚えてくれます
はい
先程ちょっと
話してたんですけれども
もうＡＰＵが開学した時から
日本語を教えてるんですね？　ＡＰＵで
はい　ＡＰＵが開学した2000年の４月から
ずっと日本語を教えています
はい
僕の視聴者の中に
日本語を勉強している人が多いんですけれども
ＡＰＵで日本語を
勉強したいと思ったら—
どういう勉強を
皆さんは しますか？
まず 英語基準で入学すれば—
日本語の必修のクラス
というのがあって
16単位分は必修で日本語を
必ず勉強しなければいけないんですけど
それが終わった後
中上級とか上級とかっていう—
更に上に行く授業もありますし
その他にも 漢字だけを
集中して勉強するクラスとか
そういうクラスがあるので—
自分で自分のやりたいクラスを取る
というのがありますし
それ以外にも
SALCという
言語自主学習センターで
会話の練習の相手をしてくれたり
アドバイスをしてくれたりする先輩がいるので
そこに行って練習したり
あとはＡＰＵにいると
生活の中で…
例えばアルバイトに行って
上手になるという人も多いですし
これが大きいと思いますね
僕も—
東京の大学に留学したんですけど
その時にインターンシップをしたんですね
やはり その…
授業の中でも
もちろん たくさん学べるんですけれども
当然 環境を変えて
これを どうしても日本語で
やらなければならないってなったら…
授業では絶対できない勉強も
たくさんあると思います
英語基準でＡＰＵに来た時は
必須で勉強しなければならない日本語の授業が
あるとおっしゃっていたと思うんですけど
その授業が終わったら
大体どのくらい会話できますか？
あと漢字は
このくらいできますというのは？
漢字は300字 ぐらいですね
すみません
全部終わった後は500字 ぐらいかな
なんですけど 500字 といっても
日本の中学生が終わるまでに勉強する漢字が
2200字 ちょっとあるんですけど
その漢字の中の500字 というと
少ないな というイメージがあるかもしれませんが—
その２千何百字の中には
ものすごく簡単な漢字も入っていて
でもＡＰＵで勉強する500字の
漢字の中には—
すごく簡単な漢字は
日常生活で覚えられるから ということで
入っていない
逆に？
かなり500字 でも
ある程度のところまではできますし
ちょっと　あまり高度な
インターンシップとかは難しいですけど—
普通のアルバイトだったら
問題なくできるレベルになるという感じですね
もう１つ 僕がいつも視聴者に言っているのは—
“日本語で何がしたい？”
それが自分で分かったら
その答えが出たら—
それに向けての勉強計画を
作ったほうがいいと思うんです
自分に合った計画を—
できるだけ早い段階で
立てたほうがいいと思うんですね
そういった意味で
ＡＰＵで できる書道の授業だったり—
ビジネスを勉強できる授業とか
選択できるのは
すごく いいなと思うんですね
そうですね
日本語のプログラムの中でも
自律学習と言って
自分で自分の勉強の仕方を—
きちんと計画できる
ということも
そういう力をつけることも
１つの目標にしていて
自分で１週間どんなことを
どういう時に日本語に触れたか
そのような振り返りをして
自分がどのくらい
どういう日本語を覚えたかを いったん考えて
自分が どういう形で日本語を
伸ばしていけるかを自分で決める
そういうことも
クラスの中でやっていたりして
そのように自分で選んで
自分の勉強の仕方を見つけていけるのは
とても いいことだと思う
ですね
前に 卒業した学生に
インタビューしに行ったことがあって
そこで その学生が言っていたのが—
日本に留学することを考えたときに
もし日本の他の大学に行っていたら—
自分の国と日本という
二項対立　２つ の意識
そういう考え方になっていたと思うけど
ＡＰＵに行ったら
日本は80の国の中の１つ
自分の国もその中の１つ
そういう意識ができた
というのが 他の大学じゃなくて
ＡＰＵに行ってよかったところだと思っていると
そうですね
ある学生が就職の
面接の時に会社の方に…
会社の方は質問することが
なくなってしまって
“あなたは自分を動物に例えたら何ですか？”と
質問をしたそうなんですね
そしたら その学生が
“ゴキブリです”と
“え？”と相手が言ったら
“世界中どこに行っても生きていく自信があります”と
すばらしいですね
はい　ではＡＰＵの日本語教育について
いろいろ皆さん
学べたんじゃないかなと思いますので
ここで終わりにしたいと思うのですが
本田先生　ありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
はい　すみません
最後に 教学部長の
メイルマノフ･セリック教授とお話ししました
彼はカザフスタン出身で
長崎大学医学部で研究し 教員を務めた後
2009年にＡＰＵに着任しました
教学部長として
ＡＰＵのカリキュラムを監督しています
日本語を勉強したことがなくても
ＡＰＵに入学し
学士課程から勉強できるのは
すばらしいと思う
多くの人が 高校を出たら
すぐに日本の大学に行きたかったと思ってる
でも日本語ができないと無理だと
思って諦めてしまう
ＡＰＵだったら
日本語を全く話せなくても入れる
本当に そのとおりだよ　道元
国際学生にとって日本語は
大きな言語の壁なんだ
でもＡＰＵは 最初から日本語が
分からなくても
日本で学部や大学院で
学べるという数少ない大学の１つなんだ
学部生ならＡＰＵにいる間に
日本語を勉強できる
ＡＰＵは他の大学とは
似ても似つかない学校で
ただ日本語を勉強しに来たとしても
すごく特殊な環境なんだ
ええ　日本語の習得は各学生の
進路にもつながってくる
国際学生の多くは
日本に興味があるから来ているけれど—
自分は卒業後に何をするのか
真剣に考え始める
ＡＰＵ生の大学卒業後の
就職率は かなり高い
平均して95%の卒業生が
就職していて
その多くは
ここ日本で就職している
日本語と母語 そして他の言語を
話せるようになるのは
大きな強みになるんだ
海外進出を考えている日本企業に
とっては需要がある
ＡＰＵで いい経験だと思ったのが
ジムなんだ
世界各国から来た学生が集まって
お互いから英語や日本語を
学ぶために友達になっているのではなく
共通の趣味があるから
友達なんだ
そのような関係性のほうが
言語に関して学べることが多いと思う
そうだよな
私は言語を学ぶことに加えて—
文化を理解することも
日本に留学することの醍醐味だと思う
ＡＰＵでは異文化理解に
重きを置いていて
ＡＰＵに入学してくる新１年生
全員に—
ＡＰハウスに住む機会を与えている
ＡＰハウスは生活の中で—
日本文化を学んで
理解する第一歩になる場所だ
実は新たなＡＰハウスを
建設する予定なんだ
来年から新しく
サステイナビリティ観光学部が設置されるから
この新しいＡＰハウスは—
ベッドの数は約260台で
建物は４階建てで
エントランスは４階に作られるんだ
面白いデザインになっていて
自然豊かな いい景色を見渡せる
学生たちが交流できる空間がたくさんある
学生同士の交流は大事だからね
なぜ新しい学部を
設置するのかというと
今 地球は安定した状態ではない
だから地球に優しい
取り組みをする上で—
“サステナビリティ”が
キーワードになってくる
新学部は環境に配慮して
持続可能な社会を目指す
というコンセプトになっている
更に国際観光などの観光の機会を
増やすという目標もある
観光も地域のコミュニティーを
維持する方法なんだ
海外から多くの人に来てもらい
文化を共有できる
そうですね
日本企業が求めているのは
優秀で創造性の高い人材だ
ＡＰＵの この環境は—
学生たちが自分の個性を
見つけるのに適していると思う
そして グローバル化が
進む世界では
異文化を理解するのも大切だ
ＡＰＵでの生活は世界に出る前の
いい練習になるよ
そのとおりだと思う
今の状況が まさにそれだよ
僕は日本に住む
アメリカ人のユーチューバーで
セリック先生はカザフスタン出身で
日本で教師を務めている
そして僕たちは
日本の大学について話している
日本で起きていることの
縮図になっている
とてもいい例えだね
数年前はこんな状況は想像できなかったね
道元の視聴者の中で—
日本に興味を持ってる人がいたら
日本を訪れるのも夢じゃない
今回は教学部長のセリック先生に
来ていただきました
お時間をいただき
ありがとうございました
これから入ってくる学生に
伝えたいことはありますか？
こちらこそ
すばらしいインタビューをありがとう
皆さんの中でＡＰＵについて
もっと知りたい人がいれば—
毎週行われる
オンライン説明会があります
英語で行われるので ＡＰＵについての
詳しい情報を知ることができます
どうも ありがとうございました
こちらこそ
いかがでしたか？
実際に 本学で勉強している学生
そして先生方の話を聞いて—
ＡＰＵが どんな大学なのか
参考になればと思います
僕は近々 ＡＰＵとオンライン説明会を
開催するので概要欄をご覧ください
この動画のスポンサーであるＡＰＵに
感謝申し上げます
では皆さん またお会いしましょう
さようなら